[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une image symbolique celle de cette
couverture du magazine américain time
et cette oeuvre monumentale de l'artiste
jr certains habitants de kiev préfère
vivre en permanence sous terre dans
cette station de métro où des familles
entières sont installés cette petite
fille de 5 ans a trouvé refuge dans ce
wagon immobilisé depuis plus de trois
semaines maintenant
l'histoire le jugera à histoire et il ya
une cour pénale internationale liste
noire connaissent pas l'histoire
l'histoire dira les dira les choses
l'humidité les conditions sont telles
qu'on risque d'attraper froid mais on
vient ici pour rester en vie ici le
quotidien s'organise progressivement
après on peut toujours discuter un
morceau de terre milles à l'heure dans
un pays où les gens votent donc voilà
est ce que jamais pour moi c'est un
homme extrêmement dangereux c'est un
tyran et aujourd'hui effectivement c'est
un criminel de guerre dont les années 60
en pleine guerre froide le régime
soviétique construit le métro de kiev
l'un des plus profonds au monde qui peut
se transformer en bunker en cas
d'attaqué nucléaire américaine ironie du
sort 60 ans plus tard il sert à protéger
ses habitants des bombes russe et face à
cet état de fait et c'est que la france
de défendre de nouveau une puissance
militaire autonome ou un rapport du
sénat qui rappelle tristement que si
nous étions il ya d'une guerre
d'authenticité nous aurions que trois
jours de munitions dont des étapes d'une
graduation qui à mon sens le conduit
aujourd'hui un isolement total
à l'échelle mondiale et je pense à mon
sens à la fin de la guerre poutine nous
voulons vivre nos voisins qui veulent
nous voir morts
place pour le compromis et on sait
comment il tient le système y compris en
interdisant toute information sur ce qui
se passe en ukraine et donc c'est un
système organisé c'est un système
dictatorial ont fusé la même classe
[Musique]
la destruction totale
notre peuple notre état une culture et
même de notre
le cren de l'israël mais nous sommes
aussi là pour rappeler ensemble que la
france et israël israël et la france
sont ensemble déterminé
c'était il y a dix ans mohamed merah tué
sept personnes à toulouse et à montauban
journée d'hommage aujourd'hui avec
quelques 2000 personnes nous sommes
déterminés à anéantir
l'antisémitisme y compris celui qui se
cache sous le masque de l'antisionisme
on assiste en ce moment dépôt de gerbe
au pied de l'arbre de vie voilà avec le
chef d'état français emmanuel macron et
le président israélien n'est plus
possible qu'aujourd'hui la consultation
habituelle des sites djihadistes ne
soient pas pénalisés avec moi elle le
sera et par ailleurs tout étranger qui
prennent la haine sera renvoyé
immédiatement rater le moment où il s'y
fait son deuxième mandat il peut plus
être élus enfin sauf si change la
constitution m'enfin il l'a pas annoncé
il se sentira totalement libres de mener
toutes les politiques antisociales qui
veut mettre en oeuvre et qu'il n'a pas
pu faire pendant le premier quinquennat
et va même plus loin donc le vote
présidentiel du 10 avril prend l'alluré
si vous voulez d'un référendum sociale
en rejoignant le cortège jean luc
mélenchon sait déjà que ce moment est le
sien la marche pour la 6ème république
c'est le ciment de ces trois
candidatures à la présidentielle un
autre monde est nécessaire et parce
qu'il est nécessaire alors nous allons
le rendre possible et le 24 avril votre
bulletin de vote vaut autant que celui
de votre banquier que celui du président
de la république que celui de bernard
arnault a dit c'est nous qui allons
bâtir ce monde nouveau et commencer à le
faire ici et maintenant